Okay Michael, so what are our features? When we
have a bunch of documents let's say full of words?
>> I'm not sure, it could be things like the number of words in the document?
>> That could be, but what sort of,
and that's actually perfectly reasonable thing but what's the
simpliest set of features that you might start with
from which you might then compute more interesting features?
>> Well there's a super, duper big set of features which are the words.
>> Right, so in
fact that is exactly what we have, is we have words.
Maybe we have punctuation and, you know. Words are sort of the
obvious thing to do. I typed in machine learning, why don't
I just return every single document that has machine followed by learning.
>> Maybe you should.
>> Maybe I should and maybe that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to do. In the case of
machine learning, should I return documents that contain
the word Machine but don't contain the word learning?
>> I wouldn't score them very highly.
>> I might not score them as highly, but I might still return
them as being at least more relevant
than documents that contain neither Machine nor Learning.
>> Right, that are just about turtles, say.
>> Right exactly, although it's turtles all the way down Michael.
>> I see.
>> OK. So if our features are words, which are the sort of the most
obvious things to get at, we can compute
other things like the number of words or
whatever. But basically our features are going to be
words or counts of words or something like
that. As it's sort of a. Reasonable first
step. And, in fact, the very early retrieval
systems, which, you know, predate both of us, actually Michael,
used simple things like words. Now, there's a lot of
way, details to this you could imagine. Like maybe you'd
want to transform all plurals into their singular version, get
rid of words like the. And there's a bunch of
complicated stuff you might want to do. But, it's not particularly
relevant for this discussion. So, just assume whatever you want
to assume about the kind of words that you have. Okay?
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, what's the problem
with using words? Can you think of any problems with using words?
>> Well, there's a lot of them.
>> Right. That's actually the first thing.
There's a lot of words. Which means there
are a lot of features. Which means
the curse of dimensionality is going to hurt us.
>> I would think that they'd be
pretty good indicators of meaning, except I guess
there's kind of two complimentary problems. One is
that some words mean more than one thing.
>> Mm. I like that. So we have good indicators.
Words are good indicators of meaning because, you
know. The words, but, you could be in the
case where you have words mean multiple things. You
said there were two problems, what's the second one.
>> Sort of the opposite, which is, you
can say the same thing using completely different words.
>> yes. So that's that many words mean the same thing. In
particular, words, the fact that words
can have multiple meanings. It's called polysemy.
The fact that many words can mean the same thing is called synonymy. So, can
you think of a word that might have
multiple meanings? That indicates the problem of polysemy?
>> Well, so, you know, learning, in the machine learning example,
learning. Sometimes refers to, this statistical process that we've been talking
about. But it also refers to the thing that, people do.
And in some, in some scenarios, it actually means to teach. Like,
I'm going to learn you something.
>> That's true, but that's just too on point.
I'm going to pick something else. That I think you
will appreciate at the end. Let's think of a
word like car. So car has multiple meanings, Michael.
>> Hmm.
>> Can you think of them?
>> I'm mostly stuck on one at the moment. Unless you're thinking of.
>> Which one is that?
>> I'm thinking of the vehicle that you drive around.
>> Yes.
>> But I guess one could also be referring to
a list deconstruct or in LISP.
>> Yes, exactly. It's the first in what are those things called?
>> CON, CON cells?
>> CON. Thank you. Right, so car is
either an automobile or it's the first element
in a cons cell, which all of you people who've heard of lisp knows is an awesome
reference. [LAUGH] For those of you who've never
used lisp, which is clearly the greatest language every
written in all of history, or that ever
will be written. Because it is a superset and
subsumes all other languages, including natural languages. Imagine this
word, instead, is apple. And so apple can refer
to a fruit, or it can refer to a
computer company, or to a music company for that matter.
>> Hm.
>> But, I prefer car. So, car can mean
automobile, or it can mean the first element in
a cons cell. If you're using Lisp. Now sticking
to this car example synonymy is a similar problem
in that car and automobile often refer to the same thing. So
you see this. So polysemy is a problem multiple things and synonymy
is a problem meaning the same thing. And a paticular word like
car in this case. Can cause both polysemy problems and synonymy problems.
>> Yeah, I can see that. So in the
example you gave before about machine learning, you would,
if you'd just returned documents that had machine and
learning right after each other, then you'd miss all
the stuff on, for example, data mining. Right, in fact, that's
a very good example so, there's a huge split in the community
between those who care about data mining and those who care about
machine learning. And often the people in one camp don't believe the
people in the other camp are doing what they're doing. But for
the person who isn't religiously commited to one of those camps or
the others, when you talk about machine learning you probably also care
about data mining. When you talk about data mining you probably also
care about what people inside the field might call it instead
of machine learning. And so you would be missing out on
a whole swath of papers or interetinst discussions if you happend
to put in the word machine learning. But similarly if you put
in the word like data mining you might end up getting
all kinds of documents that are about the data or about the
data than you get when you literally mine for ocal. Who
knows? And it would cause you huge problems for getting the exactly
relelvant set of documents that you want. So we
can actually talk about this in terms of, the
kind of errors that you get in say supervised
learning, what kind of errors do polysemy give you, Michael?
>> False, well there's false positive and false negative and
this one of the things where we, its going to return
things that aren't relevant, its going to say they're positive when
they're not. So you've given me the answer, false positive. Okay.
>> Looks like false positive.
By contrast synonymy gives you what?
>> True positives.
>> No,
>> No wait, I negated the wrong word, false negatives.
>> Exactly.
>> In other words it's going to, wait is that right? Does the, so false
negative means, oh it's going to tell you
something's not there, when actually it really is.
>> Right, so
>> Typing in car will not just give me the automobile
articles about my Tesla, which is a black P85. With black leather,
[LAUGH] fully loaded and is like the greatest car on
the planet, but it will also give me really awesome, but
in this case not what I'm looking for, documents about LISP.
Meanwhile, when I type in car, I will actually get all
these things on automobiles. But I won't get articles that
talk about automobiles without actually using the word car. So you
can imagine that these sorts of problems come up all the
time. You've got a set of features, in this case words,
which have this problem that although they're good indicators. They
are insufficient, that is we have a set of features
that will generate false positives and false negatives on their
own and more to the point, doing feature selection will
not solve this problem. I can throw away a bunch
of irelivent words and even useless words, but I am
still going this problem of generating false positives. For our
polysemy and false negatives, or synonomy. And this goes beyond
simply, information retrieval and text retrieval into
any generic problem where you have possibly
a large set of features that have
this problem with false negatives and false positives.